We covered a lot of
ground in this lesson.
You've learned about user research,
which allows you to figure
out what users' needs are,
what they say they want, and
how they use existing products.
>> We also learned about validating your
idea through market demands, trends, and
competitive analysis.
Sometimes, as you validate your
original idea might change or
be scrapped, and that's okay.
Like any good entrepreneur, you have
to continue validating your hunches.
>> Once you have a valided idea and
something users want, you'll need to
deliver a product to the end user.
We'll cover how to think
about your users and
how to design great experiences for
them in the next lesson.